dirty Lopez parlez he comes up short and
the shippers bring it back new Williams
a love the jail become a pretty good
connector with the Andre on that long no
it didn't and you see Lou Williams you
know talk about how he's involved as a
player each year in the league but this
is one of the I think one of the
greatest assets to the store from afield
bird teams of seven covers on top
Thornwell will come in and West Johnson
with two fouls will come out who goes
wherever he wants to go and see 49:47
Lakers by a pair that one who brought to
you by Hyundai
felt like he is back in Georgia right
here in his high school days when he
played above the rim goodness gracious
that's a 6-1 guard Lopez back him down
another turnover for the Lakers brings
it ahead for the Clippers Griffin the
wide open three ball no respect gringo
who said this going on it will get back
to the simplicity of a simple pass to
someone and get the old way way way back
1959 the Boston Celtics you see guys
sometimes out there it and game before
game they're shooting these long shots
and plants holding heat men's ZJ for
three bring go how good does that feel
is first NBA three at the age of 27
because of West's Indra I didn't finish
my point that's what I was going with
that was we're talking about the second
overall pick
[Applause]
we can this throws down a gravy a good
part on engine teams though Williams
ball fake against Guzman for two plus
one and even if they don't get those
other guys I don't think you're gonna
find him running away from outlays the
game separately by to let you know
simply hear something from the locker
room
William somehow don't get into that
right hand and rolls it in yes I like
this little screen but the way moon
shoes his body at bunch trying to win
their third in a row there a Lovelace
raid against the Lakers in this building
on this clipper home court you know scam
report is saying